so how about we uh we uh dive right into
this
this year's story here gop's matt gates
files criminal referral against
zuckerberg for alleged false statements
under oath now before
you all get your hopes up this is a good
first step
but it's supposed to be an investigation
i'm going to tell you right away what i
think
he's just going to be like oh i was
mistaken
of course it wasn't intentional and
there you go what are you going to do
too easy
so they're trying to say basically that
he lied false statements let's read it
they say represent it from newsweek by
the way representative matt gates on
monday filed a criminal referral against
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg for
allegedly making false statements to
congress during two joint hearings in
april 2018.
gates said zuckerberg repeatedly and
categorically denied
facebook engaged in bias against
conservatives or censored content
supportive of president donald trump
however a project veritas investigation
revealed the overwhelming majority of
content
facebook's artificial intelligence
filtered was in support of trump
and other republican people and ideas
ideals
now this part's important it's going to
be hard for him to dispute because he'd
have to argue he has no idea how his
system functions
and that's going to be really bad for
their stock and for him as the leader of
the company that's a good point
yes advertisers i have no idea what
content will appear next to your ads i
have no idea why or how
they're going to be like uh isn't that
something the ceo should know
so he might have to come out and be like
well we didn't mean it that way
i think he'll avoid you know the worst
part is he'll get a fine
they'll be like we hereby find you 50
million dollars and it'll be like we
made you know how many billions last
year sure fine
the republican congressman sent a letter
to will to attorney general william barr
asking the department of justice to
investigate zuckerberg
the statements in question were made
during a house energy and commerce
committee hearing
and again at a joint hearing of the
senate judiciary committee
and the senate and the senate commerce
science and transportation committee
quote as a member of this body i
question mr zuckerberg's veracity
and challenge his willingness to
cooperate with our oversight authority
diverting congressional resources during
time-sensitive investigations
and materially impeding our work gates
said in the letter
such misrepresentations are not only
unfair they are potentially illegal and
fraudulent
potentially keyword newsweek reached out
for facebook
to facebook but they have not responded
zuckerberg told senators at the april
10th hearing that he understood concerns
legislators legislators had
about conservative censorship because
silicon valley is an extremely
left-leaning place
he said he shared that concern and it's
something he tries to root out in the
company
the next day he responded to a question
from representative steve scalise by
saying
there was absolutely no directive to
have a bias in anything we do
to the contrary our goal is to be a
platform for all ideas
now that was a lie that that's what he
said
in in congress when he was yeah you know
on the street so
responding well well here's the
challenge though our goal
what does that even mean right right it
doesn't mean they do it
rather lose exactly we can do whatever
we want my goal is to have 20 billion
dollars
yeah yeah great you know we we can all
you know go to sleep and have a nice
little dream
during veritas's undercover
investigation a facebook content
moderator
said she would delete every republican
item that showed up on her queue
she added that she doesn't remove
anti-trump content even if it violates
the
uh even if it violates the policy if
someone is wearing a maga hat
i am going to delete them for terrorism
another moderator said
i think we are all doing that now here's
another snag
this i believe was a third-party company
zuckerberg is going to say
facebook didn't do anything third party
company did
yeah at the time of the investigation's
release
james o'keefe the founder of nceo
veritas said the findings raised serious
doubts
about zuckerberg's testimony on capitol
hill o'keeffe added the
the report called into question
facebook's immunity under section 230
of the communications decent decency act
gates wrote in the letter to bar the
findings of the project veritas
investigation were in direct contrast
with zuckerberg's testimony that
facebook was a politically neutral
platform
facebook's ai screening content is not
politically neutral
neither are the moderators hired to
review content flagged by the ai program
gates told barr
this stands in opposition to
zuckerberg's congressional testimony
and violates the good faith provision of
section 230 c2a
of the communications decency act the
congressman asked barr to investigate
zuckerberg for making material
materially false statements to congress
while testifying under oath
and asked for full and proper
consideration first of all
project veritas james o'keefe bravo good
sirs excellent indeed that was
good report so few there's so little
real journalism going on
and veritas gets ripped to shreds by the
media
for going after these powerful companies
and players and i will tell you right
away
they argue that veritas is biased
they're conservative
so what does that mean when they go
after cnn
or the washington post or google or
facebook
are those companies all left leaning is
he biased for going after them
that's a good question right the answer
is of course not he's going after
he's he's speaking truth to power he's
getting people on the record that are
revealing these powerful individuals are
subverting our right to speech
now i'm not saying the first amendment
that's a government-related thing but
if they're going to host political
discourse and monopolize the commons the
space we need as people to to engage in
discourse
we got a serious problem here man i was
just looking up here um
section cc is protection for the good
samaritan blocking and screening of
offensive material so that's what it's
under
like right the good the good faith uh
provision that's what this is checked it
out
so this goes beyond just yeah well so
this is interesting it goes just
this uh referral from matt gates is one
of the first steps i mean
i suppose the first step is having them
testify yeah this referral
is extremely important even if
zuckerberg says
oopsie whoopsie i didn't know yeah what
happens now
is they opened the door for violations
of section 230
which means facebook could be sued for
literally anything posted on the site by
anyone
that's a good point and facebook is
responsible so because of their biased
actions
because we have moderators on the record
saying we violate the good faith
provisions of this
they straight up say we'll remove
someone forming a maga hat section two
defensive to them
tim no but but they're not going to be
able to successfully defend themselves
against a lawsuit saying they were
removing objectionable material when
they tell the judge
he had he had a maga head on and judge
is going to be like how is that in any
way objectionable the president wears
the hat
right well we think it's objection ah
get out of here you're
like look oh yeah they shot themselves
in a foot
that uh if you haven't seen the project
veritas um
exposing facebook videos they're lying
go check
them out so these companies
have long been violating the section
section 230 oh yeah
and the problem is i guess nobody is
actually filing the suits
you know i i don't know exactly how it
would work here's i would imagine
and correct me if i'm wrong if there's
any lawyers in the chat
somebody will say you know adam kriegler
called me a
big stupid doo-doo head on facebook it's
true i'm suing facebook
for defamation facebook would then have
to respond to the judge
section 230 defends us from liability i
would then
you know have to respond actually
facebook is in violation of the good
faith provision because they choose and
remove
outside of the confines of the good
samaritan removal
and the judge would have to be like okay
or no
and then appeal i don't know exactly how
it would work i'd imagine it would be
something like that
i did talk to a lawyer friend of mine
before about this and was told basically
people need to start filing lawsuits
that specifically
drive through the heart of section 230.
the problem is we like section 230.
what we don't like is them abusing it
right by abusing it
they're able to tilt the whole
conversation now
i suppose there is a net benefit in the
sense that the silent majority
exists and it's been emboldened
and embiggened if you would by it's
actually a word now apparently really
and bigen yeah it's in the dictionary uh
simpson's reference
the so the silent majority i was looking
up i guess it's a reference to nixon
okay like the p you know i think it was
nixon was nixon yeah
yeah he was like i'm appealing to you
know the general ideas the people who
don't engage in politics
but have real concerns they're not just
speaking up all the time
okay because of what these social media
companies have done with bias
and just basically nuking conservatives
and
and like i got to stop there okay people
keep saying it's biased against
conservatives this is important
it's actually not it's biased against
people who oppose
the far left right now because the
conservatives
are most likely to be the ones standing
up and speaking out against the far left
they're the ones who are being nuked
indiscriminately yeah but there
are absolutely liberal individuals who
will say something about say like you
know trans issues and then be nuked
and they're not conservative right
they'll get banned in fact there are
some really anti-trump people who have
been banned for talking about
you know talking bad of
intersectionalism and even anti-war
progressives who have been nuked
entirely like
uh youtube i'm sorry twitter purged a
ton
of progressive anti-war activists so
that's what
that's what it's really about it's like
if you oppose the establishment
orthodoxy
yeah well i mean i think the the whole
reason it's a silent majority is
these people aren't on twitter they're
not i mean maybe they're on facebook
more than twitter but i have a feeling
they're not even on any of those things
did you hear what happened in chicago
when they the day after they took down
the columbus statue no what happened so
they took the the mayor of chicago
finally said all right fine we'll take
down the statue because the
rioters have been demanding it at a.m
yep overnight they went and snuck and
got it got it out big too
yeah it was statue it was a big statue
so the italian americans
in chicago were pissed they are really
mad they they went out and they were
like you know what
we we got that statue we we legally
wanted it we we like went through the
process we legally
got it and and did it and put it up for
for them to
give in to the demands of these
terrorists that are terrorizing our city
shows how how wrong the
the the government bro and there's and
we're standing up
we you started a war like they're like
we're
you you activated us uh mayor lightfoot
like
you you did this so we're coming the
silent majority is being embiggened
is that is that what is the the well let
me just say this real quick
uh you said that the guy was basically
saying
you've given in to the demands of the
far left terrorizing us yep
no she didn't she is the far left
terrorizing them that's a good point
well that's not the way they see it
though right i know i know but my point
is
if if 100 people come out with sickle
and hammers all over themselves
and they're yelling marks over and over
again and throw ropes over a statue and
try and pull it down
and then the mayor comes in and goes
stop stop
we brought a crane yay she's with them
you're right you mean it's true but why
do it at three in the morning
that's just dirty stop the the other
people from showing up and stopping her
you're right
she basically she basically was like hey
all of you crazy terror people
mm-hmm stop what you're doing please
don't you understand
we're gonna do it way better we're gonna
do it at three in the morning with a big
crane and no one will stop us
this so uh the ambiguan reference is uh
simpson's joke where i can't remember
who it was miss krabappel or whatever
she says i've never heard the word i'm
big in there watching a
story about jebediah springfield the
founder yeah he's like a noble spirit
and biggins even the smallest man or
something
she's like she's like i've never heard
the word i'm big until moving to
springfield
and then the other teacher goes and
begins a perfectly cromulent word
now ambigan and cromulent are actual and
they're in the dictionary
it's just like perfectly acceptable yeah
it mean
right it means like form-fitting and
acceptable or something or like
context is everything yeah i've got it
right here in begin to enlarge or grow
or to make or become bigger yeah perfect
all right i'm biggen
i i i actually i i don't know if it if
it existed before and they were making a
joke about it i don't think that's
exactly accurate because it's more
emboldened
like they they're they're not just i
mean to enlarge you know to grow
sure but it's it's they're already there
the numbers are there now they're just
silent majority i'm talking about the
silent majority so so the reason why
this all ties together is that we talked
you know last week about this cato
institute study
that found 62 percent of americans are
afraid to speak about their political
opinions
and the only okay so you've got strong
liberal
liberal moderate conservative strong
conservative guess which
one was comfortable expressing
themselves in public
the far left the only ones the the
loudest screamers
the it was the staunch liberal yeah and
only by about 52
i think like half felt that they could
speak their opinions in public
without offending anybody now that's
either extreme
ignorance like they're really dumb just
like why would anyone be offended about
me saying i'm gonna repeal civil rights
legislation you know what i mean like
certainly that's offensive to a ton of
people i'm certainly offended about it
yeah me too
but they don't think it's offensive to
say the crazy thing for the most part is
when i tell people about this they don't
believe it they're like
i have a friend who goes out marches for
this stuff and then
literally believes that because she
wearing her frilly flower dress holds up
a sign
that we are calling her antifa and so
i'm like no no no no i was like are you
going around smashing windows
are you going around tearing things down
and beating people no one is talking
about you
but i will say you provide the shield
the mass for those people to go out and
destroy things
yep so that i will criticize but when i
said to her i was like you have to you
have to understand why i'm not a fan of
what you're doing
i understand protesting police brutality
and all that stuff but you're actively
supporting people who are appealing
civil rights law and her response is
like
prove it and i'm like done here's the
link this doesn't make sense someone
must be getting paid off i don't
understand what's happening
yeah well maybe that was the response
yeah maybe maybe you should
you should not go out and hold up like
you know what man
it reminds me of that thing that
happened at the cernovich event in new
york
where a bunch of antifa were protesting
mike cernovich speaking at colombia
somebody walked up the front of the
march and unfold this big banner and
said please hold this
and they did wow and it was a pro
nambla poster do you know what namble is
i don't think i want to know the north
american man boy love
association
because they did not read what they were
flying
the mindlessness of what they're doing
yeah
that's so gross yep somebody that
movement is disgusting
somebody tricked these antifa into
flying that banner
and the there's a video of them carrying
it for uh i think like a minute or so a
couple minutes until someone else
noticed and ran up and snatched it
ripped it up i was like what are you
doing
yeah and they were confused like what do
you mean like we're just holding the
banner
that someone gave us ignorance
imagine what you must like to the people
who would would go out and fly these
signs
without reading them i i said this last
month ignorance is a is a
really crazy pandemic running through
our society right now
among our younger generation that's what
it really feels like well it's like you
were talking about before people want to
be youtubers
yep exactly yeah and here we are as
youtubers well i mean
yeah and that's funny actually a friend
of mine and i were talking about that
basically
saying like how can you you sit there
being a youtuber calling out how younger
generations
you know want like it's bad that they
want to be a youtubers it's like
yeah the difference is i didn't want to
be a youtuber
that's not what i set out to do i set
out to
i mean i was a pro skater you know i was
you know modeling traveling around the
world doing that for a long time trying
to be
a musician you know so i had other
things and then you called me and you
were like do you want to do the show and
i was like all right i'm not doing
anything well actually it was like do
this remember that show we tried doing a
couple years ago yeah let's
do it again we did try we did try the
show now we have
equipment well and and we were under
someone else's authority
now we can do our we're doing our own
stuff you know i would say this
when they say they want to be youtubers
they're not talking about news
and politics and and activism they just
want to be famous
no well no that's what it is they just
want the fame they want to be famous
that's what it is
they think there was there was this very
famous youtube uh young woman who like
had a mental breakdown after
getting like a million plus subs because
what ends up happening is these people
don't realize you you're digging a hole
and you get trapped in it
where it's like i i think about bands
that break up right okay i was thinking
about like fallout boy
you know they were moderately big in the
2000s and they broke up
and then they got back together later
you know why because they got sick of it
it was too much work this is my
assumption by the way i don't know
exactly why they broke up they're
probably like i want to do other things
okay so they quit then the money dries
up real fast
and then they're like oh i really
enjoyed having tons of money and
fancy living yeah let's go back to
working so what happens to these young
people is
when they reach this epic proportion on
youtube it takes a ridiculous amount of
work
and now all of a sudden they're trapped
where they're like i have my dream
if i stop now i'll lose everything and
so they refuse to let it go
and they get trapped in that cycle
become really depressed and then these
these people who watch these kids they
think it's
all glory and glamorous they don't
realize it's
it's man fame and celebrity all this
stuff has always been glamorized
and it's always just it's just people
don't get it's not the case newsflash
by the way i don't want to be a youtuber
you know i am certainly enjoying myself
i i am i
really the critical thinking i feel like
i've learned
an incredible amount of stuff over the
past six months you know but
my end game is not to just do this
forever you know i would love to
further my music career i still really
would like to do that maybe i would try
acting sometime like
or or get into politics you know i
thought about that for
the past couple years do you know what
the sword of damocles is
it's no what is it do you know the story
i'm familiar with this story
are you are you are you confident do you
want to tell it i'm not confident enough
to tell it
well my general understanding is
basically this dude was like so this guy
right you know he walks up to the king
and he goes yo king
you're so lucky being king and the
king's like you think so he goes yeah
i wish i was king and he was like i'll
tell you what how would you like to be
king for a day and he's like well i'll
be king bro
so then the king is like all right come
back tomorrow and come sit on the throne
and you're king he's like dude awesome
so the dude shows up the next day and he
sits down and he looks up and there's a
sword hanging by a hair right over his
head
and he goes what is this and the king's
like
that's a sword about to drop at any
moment being hung by
by a hair and the guy is like i don't i
don't want to be king anymore i don't
want to be king
and the king basically said you have
you're a big target with a sword hanging
over your head that could snap at any
moment
everybody you know basically the gist is
when you're doing politics like this you
make enemies
you know when you when when when so
actually to wrap it up back to what
we're talking about with facebook's bias
when adam kriegler does a video where
he's like you know
you say you want to vote for trump then
it goes up on facebook and facebook
nukes it yep
yeah because they're like we don't like
this guy we're gonna come after him well
it's funny you should you should bring
up trump
also because he was told all his friends
were like people are gonna hate you
you're gonna you're gonna get hated
people are gonna run you through the
ringer and he's like
whatever it doesn't matter dude i feel
like the country needs me
and i believe it i think i think it
really does deeply affect him though
because he's this guy who's always like
could you imagine living your entire
life with
everyone praising you all the time hit
tv
show your name big gold letters
everybody loves you they say the
american dream is to be donald trump
and then as soon as you run for
president it's like 70 years you know 60
plus years
of being like i don't know what it was
like when he was younger though but like
he had this
period of adulthood where he was the
best of the best everyone loved him
that's true now all of a sudden the
media was just
tearing him to shreds every day
i think they're they're that that's
coming to an end though because
people are becoming aware of of who he
actually is
as far as outside the media realm
you know yes but i think the bigger
issue is
when a group of people romp around your
town smashing everything and destroying
your life
you start to ask questions about what's
really going on more importantly
when you notice that you know your
friends and your family are suffering
under the destruction of all these
businesses and the media won't talk
about what's happening you have to
question
what are they talking about why more
importantly when you see
far left people in all black smash up
the window of your favorite restaurant
and then jerry nadler comes out waddles
up to the microphone and goes
antifa is a myth you go wait what they
just smashed up my restaurant
well in he didn't say antifa he said the
the riots
in portland were a myth he initially
said i i
remember where he said it somewhere in
like a house committee oh okay in a
different different time okay yeah maybe
maybe there's context here it's missing
but the general idea was that antifa
is a myth yeah and then when it was
brought up to him
by flecca about the uh fluke as a
youtuber and personality
about the rights in portland he says the
rioting and stuff that's all a myth it's
only talked about in dc
yeah and now it's only spread only
spread in dc
so crazy when you have people in oregon
literally
super chatting us during the show being
like i can't stand this yeah like these
people need to stop
trump needs to send them in it's like
that's true that almost every show
they're they're super chatting
saying look i live here and this is
insane we want we want it to end i live
here
please help it end and you know the
funny thing about it is
i posted a i posted a clip from some
photos from michael tracy's reporting of
the
there's restaurant there's there's a
market it says please don't hurt us
please don't hurt us we support black
lives matter nightmares
sad yeah it is horrifying i posted this
and i get a response from someone saying
hey man i live in portland everyone's
fine
and i'm like here's an article from the
oregonian of people who own businesses
downtown saying we're suffering yeah we
need the police to solve the
because the police are standing down in
many instances and only dealing with the
rights of the protests
crime has gone up apparently general
crime what a surprise
yeah and so they're also saying nobody
wants to show up nobody wants to come
down here because
there's chaos and violence at night yeah
and the whole thing gets destroyed
so people don't show up now these
businesses are suffering so you know
what fine maybe for the most part
portland is okay
but when did we ever be like we're a
nation of 330 million and we're willing
to sacrifice
those people yeah that that 100 000
people in the gutter
you know what i'm going to take this
this moment to just shout out phillip
anderson because he is
oh yeah he is standing in front of them
in front of
this entire crowd that's trying to bring
down the the courthouse
and yelling at him to stop please stop
you you guys are using violence
and uh man there's there's plenty of
videos out there he's been banned twice
on twitter and they're telling him
i watched that video you posted the
antivirus people are like go home get
out of here
and he's like no yeah he's like no i'm
not i'm not gonna leave what are you
talking about like
i'm here to because you guys are here
like i want you all to stop like
you know he's like you know i am i'm the
person you say matter
so if if i matter prove it to me think
about this
you got these people the silent majority
that don't
stand up they mind their own business
they go to work and now they're being
forced to come out
people like what was it named phillip
phillip yeah yeah he's coming out
he doesn't seem like a guy who normally
does this maybe you're right you know
but now he's not
now you did it now you now you woke up
people they're getting all angry and
they're coming out yeah
and and it's look man rasmussen's
polling
trump is doing better than ever maybe
it's wrong could be wrong it could be a
close race
oh he's doing better better than ever
for sure silent majority is massive
it's not silent anymore man they're
standing up i see it i see it more and
more now videos of people grouping up
and there there was i don't remember
what town it was but there was a small
town in america
where there was like a group of 10 maybe
15 i don't want to say antifa i don't
want to say black lives
matter because i don't know who was who
anymore
but they were just completely swallowed
up
by this american flag waving crowd and i
was just
yes do you hear about the dude it felt
so good to see that you're about to do
to try to run over the blue lives matter
rally what no i think it was that
colorado eaton colorado yeah in colorado
oh
man he jumped a curb they arrested him
yeah
he jumped the curb and like drove out
and people got out of the way wow yup
the people who see here's the thing
they're crazed the people who are
speaking up you know no longer staying
silent they get
like they try to kill them you know yeah
i think there's uh obvious reason why
they need to make sure they stay silent
to keep the perception that this country
is far left
and it's really funny to me when i see
these progressive pundits use excuses
and manipulative polls
to say things like america really is a
progressive country here's the proof
they do really clever things with
polling like
you know they'll ask you frank luntz
talks about this how they'll ask you a
question
and then draw a twisted conclusion based
off what they ask you
right like would you be in support of
deporting an illegal immigrant child
from this country
you know like on their own and then it's
like it's very extreme if those people
say no and then it'll say
you know 90 percent of people uh uh
oppose deportations
they won't give you the full contact so
then yes you know and then all this
context is everything
right yep there's clever ways they can
do this they can also
they can also ask you questions to
guarantee the answer they want oh yeah
so see that i don't know any examples up
top in my head but it's basically just
how they frame the question
you know like like i just showed you
would you then you say of course i would
not you know and then
ask an answer that there's only one one
answer
but but insert a little bit of
information that they can twist
i see that a lot actually would you
support deporting people
who you know entered this country
illegally yes or no
and then you'll get you know yes or no
answer right but then you can taint the
question
you know children or you know the
marginalized peoples
yeah we used to do this all the time
when i worked in a call center because
we were doing outgoing calls we were
asking people poll questions
so we'd ask them political questions and
you could always tell who was funding it
even though it was usually like a pack
like a super pac or something
i don't know what progress for america
is or why they're buying this person's
polling data but i'm reading these
questions and i can tell exactly what
they want people to say and they're
saying
and you know what trump does it too yeah
i love it i love it i get these emails
and it'll be like do you uh you know how
it's like how would you rate the
president's performance in the past year
superb excellent great other i just see
it and i laugh
yeah but but that's i think meant to be
silly like
because the you know i was thinking
about this when it comes to the culture
war
i was uh what's that new prageru video
uh from carlin
yeah she's talking about going to a
trump rally yeah yeah yeah yeah and she
talks about how the trump rally
everyone's laughing and singing and
dancing like a rock show and
waving american flags and then the
democrat thing is like doom and gloom
and like
racist and horrible yeah i love the
there's one line in there that just said
make america civil again and i was just
like yes
well i think that we need that it's it's
the true liberals and conservatives
that are actually civil with each other
right now yeah and then you have the
fringe far left
and you know i'm i'm this is this is
true i've said i've said this before but
the far left
wants trump to win cnn wants trump to
win i need him
they do they do you see cnn's ratings
are going to tank if biden wins
so what they have to do is pretend they
hate trump while trying to find a way to
actually
make sure he wins interesting we'll see
if they actually
i mean it's it's an assumption i'm not
saying it's it's true but i'm saying
what is true is that cnn has benefited
great greatly
from trump's presidency okay and jeff
zucker the president of cnn
uh he was the apprentice guy right he
ran nbc he ran nbc yeah so
they know that trump is a gold mine
that's why they
they love that he's an office trump bump
yeah the trump bump they call it
the far left feels similarly if
donald trump loses and joe biden wins
all of these sleepy liberals will
immediately disavow the far left
they'll become the far left will be
marginalized no one will support them no
one will link arms to protect them
because
joe biden's president it happens every
time when george w bush was president
you had the famous 2004 rnc
where a bunch of far leftists got
arrested for having molotov cocktails
right and shields and bats and stuff
then obama gets elected and
they don't do anything i mean a little
bit there was black lives matter riots
but that wasn't
targeting barack obama himself well
there was a lot of molotov cocktails
last night in portland
yeah they found a couple well they found
a couple but then there was also
um a bunch of of they weren't molotovs
but they were
mason jars sealed all along but they
found them yeah they found them all yeah
no
not not the police the police reported
that they found uh two months
but there was a bunch yeah yeah this is
a full separate report of mason jars
surrounding the fence oh wow that uh
didn't have rags in them but i can only
imagine it was they're full of flames
probably something so you could throw
them probably you know yeah this is one
of their tactics they leave
resources lying around for people and
the cops the cops found magazines loaded
magazines
and and mason jar molotovs with rags
coming out thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live monday through friday at
8pm if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you